chez seb alors pour la saison oui on
sait c'est bien oui mais c'est génial
waouh ces matches-là poteau à sa droite
pour le soudan monsieur c'est bien ça me
fait pour ça c'est beau c'est c'est bof
c'est bien c'est beau c'est moche mais
c'est génial où il apprend mieux 5 à la
compta et lesquelles la voiture soit la
vidéo les galas mais non c'est une pub
c'est plus que j'ai réalisé mes nerfs
dans les agences de pub une dune avions
un paysage routier route
ouais enfin moi je vends du parfum et
paf votre parfum et champagne chantage
maintenant je sais youporn chez burger
king ont revenu en france mais on
n'ouvre que deux magasins
vous pensez vraiment que les gens vont
faire la queue pendant huit heures pour
un [ __ ] de morgen
non ils arrivent ils arrivent à la fois
il avait raison voilà j'avais pensé à
ckac
pas tous de la barbe dix mois pro depuis
ce jour julien jocelyn à changer de
métier
ils élèvent désormais des bichons dans
le gers et à changer de sexe il faut
optimiser attend encore une pub nous en
vue mais maintenant non
à
couche ensemble
bah oui champagne alors qu'est ce que
c'est mais pourquoi tout fait de
s'annoncer biya à votre sexe et dans ma
bouche monsieur porte un max d'argent un
max de blé mon gars honnête perdu les
droits de diffusion pour les simpson
siegel aaa
je ne sais pas
tu es un écran plus grand
mais ne s'est pas vu michel en vacances
à lui michel michel oui tu pourras
lieutenant l'autre oui oui michel
bourlet à vous dites dans les fesses en
rente et capitaine du trois symboles mis
d'accord mais non mais là les trucs tu
n'existes pas n'importe quoi j'appelle
toutes ces vielles g pour les réaliser
et permet une action on peut pas
terminer tout louga car champagne c'est
toujours quand même ça va non